at this detention center in sörman an
eerie silence prevails most of the 250
young women here tried to cross the
Mediterranean to reach Europe but they
didn't make it
Cinthia from Nigeria was in a boat that
was stopped by security forces they
brought her to this camp she says they
were caught at sea and their boat came
under gun fire and that it's God's will
that she survived
Cynthia was heavily pregnant at the time
today she has to use the detention
center toilet to change her baby's
diapers and she doesn't know if the
child will survive woman this is Laura
she says she can't nurse her daughter
because she's been unable to produce any
milk since her daughter's birth German
diplomats have compared the conditions
in many Libyan detention centers to Nazi
concentration camps they've just gone
public with their report which says the
young women are often beaten and raped
by the staff there's no phone no phone
here since 5:00 most have not spoken
tonight there is nobody
we are just here what we are begi there
for me just for obscurity cause once I
come true there's all the media the
managing staff in some camps are even
accused of human trafficking the camp
director in sermon disputes this he
accuses Western countries of ignoring
the horror reporters show the problems
in the poor conditions here but no one
is stepping up to help us we're not
getting any support and Mogu the staff
says medical aid is urgently needed at
this Detention Center but even if it's
delivered
no one believes that will make much of a
difference
you